hmm
foreign
[Music]
foreign
let's see
this thing needs to go
here
here
ah it's a bit large
that's better
and this can probably be like this
foreign
hello will stability be involved I don't
I don't know not yet
which program is this for streaming this
is OBS I think pretty much everyone
uses obs
at least for YouTube
I think it's it's open
the thing covered my message yes
sorry
talk about censoring and safety
mechanism
from what I've read that's a major issue
I don't think it's a a major issue
um
so it's a major issue in in
the open AI system but the safety is
just on the data side so
um personally identifiable data things
like this
um yeah that's we have to we have to
somehow well first of all make clear
that when users submit data that we are
going to use it to train stuff and so on
so they should not submit sensitive data
that they don't want in there
um and so on so
um yeah and then I think it comes down
to to to cleaning the data set but I I
am gonna Advocate strongly to not put in
this this stupid I am a large language
model I am not able to to do this and
that like that's it's so it's so
pretentious to think yeah
it's so pretentious to think that you
you are the moral Orbiter for the rest
of the world though
what Hardware
sorry I'm I haven't eaten yet so I'm I'm
gonna Munch chocolate
um what Hardware
will you run this on
um So the plan is
the plan is to get it to a point where
you can run it on consumer Hardware now
initially that might mean
or to a point where the individual
person can run it initially that might
mean you need like an AWS machine a
cheap one
um
but I think with stable diffusion it was
pretty cool to see that once they put
the model out there other people took it
and then made it smaller made it more
lightweight so that it can run on
smaller and smaller machines and if we
achieve that as well we only need to
bring it down to you know reasonable
size so that other people can take it
and then make it even more efficient and
and so on
so yeah
yeah
um what are you doing for the new year
this you see every time every time I go
on GitHub and I refresh the
notifications they're already 30 again
30. 30 of you people have
I mean no this is it's absolutely
overwhelming
um
to the the level of Engagement that
people have so I I put the the GitHub
link somewhere up here uh you can check
out the GitHub you can grab an issue you
can also make issues right that you feel
so my job is twofold first of all
um we have we have okay I will so for
for privacy for my privacy I will every
now and then have to to
um hide stuff so I quickly need to read
something that you're not allowed to see
therefore I'll do this
and I'll read whatever I need to read
and then I'll come back
um yeah that's that's just the life
because it's um yeah
could
because I also have
um my day job is a startup so
nice good okay
that's very good very I got very good
news so the job today is Administrative
believe it or not
um we do have this uh this this Discord
here which is for work coordination so
this is not if you're just interested
and so on feel free to follow us on the
GitHub repository on the um your
appropriate channels in the lion Discord
and on our Discord the the Yana culture
Discord
um the internal one here is for work
coordination so that's really for people
who want to contribute
um so if you grab a GitHub issue or
something like this
um you know we you you'll get in there
also if you if you use the sign up form
I've disabled the sign up form right now
we have to see how to continue here
because it's just an overwhelming amount
of people
which is crazy
um I'm really happy but then also okay
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
go through the new people in here who
all are contributing or wanting to
contribute
um
yeah
wait can you okay chat I need to chat
and this okay I'm not a good YouTuber
now uh yet can we swap the map mole with
random operation so it can be better
sparse but sure it's just not given that
it will also work
there is like people people who make
things faster they sometimes do
trade-offs for fastness where stuff
stops the work
and then it's like okay you just you
essentially make a a heater
um but yeah if you can find something
that works as well as Matt Mull uh in
the attention but I mean that would be
killer
um how many how many number of
parameters are good for Consumer GPU
um you know I I previously for a
previous project which I'm not going to
name but you might know it I I use the
gptj style model
um
and uh it ran fine on on one GPU so I'd
like a GPT j6b so it's it's probably
going to be around that size maybe a bit
larger because larger models do have
more knowledge
um
in like inside so yeah
uh what's your take on diffusion models
for text
um
well the fusion models seem to work for
generative things uh text is not that
easy to like noise and that has always
been a problem with text like as long as
we know image models have just been way
nicer for deep learning because
everything's like continuous and
differentiable and text is super like
it's it's just
discrete and that's not good so it but
if someone can figure out some discrete
combination yeah
um
what about training the model with
academic papers okay this is an
important Point sure
have fun I'm I'm I usually don't I don't
really drink alcohol but I'll have I
have like an iced tea or something I'm
very boring
um
no this it's an important an important
point which I think many people Miss in
the whole what do we like what data and
so on it's it's quite clear that
with for example chat GPT
um
the all of the all of the capabilities
and all of the knowledge is already in
the model like in the in the base model
in the gpt3 that they use the human
feedback on pretty much all of the
knowledge is already in there so there
is not like you you cannot use or I
don't think it's the purpose of this
human feedback loop to put more
knowledge into the model like people say
oh we can tune it to do math and so on
to a degree but what's much more
relevant with this human feedback is you
just want to use the human feedback to
get it to get the model into like a
mindset to get it into a prior state of
really being aligned with what the human
wants like to be this this assistant
right and you really wanna that's what
you do with the human fine tune you
don't you don't put new knowledge in
there you don't put new abilities in
there you simply getting into a prior
into a state where it's where it knows
essentially knows it's tuned to
fulfilled tasks and but the knowledge
that to do that is already in there and
you can see that chat GPT is like super
good at answering questions about
quantum physics and math proofs and
coding yet open AI says at least in the
instruct GPT paper they used like crowd
workers common common crowd workers
which you know you are a crowd worker if
you are if you if you don't
um
what should I say it's it's a it's a
possibility for people to earn a bit of
money on the side and usually people
with a higher degree of Education they
don't need that so there's there's just
going to be
um a lot of people with let's say less
education maybe you know or or different
education if you're like a literature
major or something like this but not not
Quantum physicists well though quantum
physics probably I'm not sure if that's
a good paid job or not however
the so you can already see that that
this knowledge does not come out of the
out of the human fine tuning
um and and that's I think quite
important to to realize
so yeah so so the the whole human
feedback thing is to really get the
model into this task fulfillment mode
and that means we need diversity of
inputs and that's why we need you that's
why we need humans to come up with
prompts to come up with Answers by the
assistant and so on and that's why we
are building right now this this whole
infrastructure to collect the human data
and that's what this this Discord is
about
um yeah so
that's that's what the whole efforts are
all right all right so wait that was one
chat question sorry
very sorry to make it lengthy I'll be
more quick can you make it browse the
web
and not be static like chat GPT
um yes yeah that's the plan uh not the
initial plan but the plan is
to make it browse the web
um to to dynamically retrieve
information we think we have a good idea
of how or good ideas of how this could
be done and we're pretty sure that you
will have even better ideas of how that
can be done so
yeah I'm I'm fairly confident we can do
that
um
let's see
[Music]
yeah
can you stop talking sure
uh
[Music]
where can I find the link to join the
Discord Channel if you're
um if you're if you're active on on like
follow follow us on the like The Lion
and the the our Discord and I'll
eventually if I have a better way of
managing all the newcomers here I'll
I'll post links there
um
yeah but this is so this is what we're
gonna do right now I'm gonna look
through the new people who came in
and we're gonna see what who they are so
they need to introduce themselves ml
practitioner what we'll do is we delete
the unverified role and we'll add the
verified role I know this can be
automated
um I know
but it's a bit of of screening because
this is really for work coordination so
we want to know a little bit who people
are
um
and oh sorry
um
yeah I don't I don't know that there's a
there's a good way because as soon as
people realize this is automated they're
just gonna write like ASDF and stuff
we're aiming to build an all-in-one chat
model we're aiming to build an assistant
like a true assistant like a thing that
you can give a task and it will do the
task at least for for knowledge work
right it's not necessarily vacuum my
kitchen but for for knowledge work so it
needs to be able to retrieve things it
also needs to be able to interact with
third-party systems like to essentially
take control of your mouse uh and
keyboard and go to another application
and do something although that's quite a
bit into the future and there are other
cool projects that do that one is called
robot me that also plans on that we'll
see if they if they
um maybe want to collaborate this could
also be built into applications
essentially if you want to make your
application AI powered
um to have your application communicate
with the human in a more natural way uh
this could also be you used for that
um
ml engineer interested in improving very
cool thank you for being here yes so my
job is essentially going through these
um reading them
and and letting them in
that's that
um yeah that's one of my jobs the other
job is to go through GitHub issues
categorize them assign them and so on
foreign
[Music]
so this person actually is already in on
a GitHub issue so we'll also give them
the contributor role
it's just about keeping the noise down
for now like really
very cool very cool
Tim
that's oh Tim Tim's doing robot me hello
Tim
thanks for being here
would love to join see I I say it and it
happens amazing
can it use AI to validate roles
yes yes we could absolutely
Tim
um watching the stream very interested
very cool
thank you for being here foreign
excellent
software developer
amazing
and new to Discord you joined for us
thank you thank you that's cool okay
caught up so far so Mars typing
um but we'll sneak away before that so
the other thing is okay
um
reading up on discussions
uh
should
end up in that repo
will it have persistent memory
hopefully I mean that's that's still
uh that's still out to do right who who
knows how to do that persistent memory
that's
what kind of background have the
contributors all kinds of background all
kinds
um really so
like I don't I don't necessarily care
too much about the background more of
what what people want to do and can do
um
yeah there's a TechCrunch article
mentioning us now
we trended yesterday on GitHub how crazy
is that
um
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
hmm
okay we're gonna have to solve this
this here
if someone wants to do something
pre-commit on a Windows 10 machine
ah windows windows
try to clone the repository again it
worked for me that's a that's such a
um
we want to change all the line endings
to l f
if config for new files but we still
need to update old files I thought
pre-commit did that
no Docker image of course yeah we have
Docker images but it's this is for con
so if you commit
uh pre-commit will yell at you if you
don't follow its its thing
um
this thing it's very good like it just
enforces style and so on and you really
need that if you work with other people
mixed line ending check replaces or
checks mixed line ending
um yeah
yeah so uh
let's see
detect mixed
line endings
yep yep
next line ending
yep
okay
I think that's good
I can't click on something here okay
well in any case
um
maybe we can solve that
yet for joining the Discord follow us on
lion and uh or the or our Discord and
I'll I'll paste the link as soon as I
have figured out how to let more people
in
um I'm not I'm not sure
um although I can probably there's not
too many people here right
um
yeah I'll post a link there I'll I'll
post it there for now for now GitHub is
the main the main place where you can
see what's happening or the open
discords I'll I'll post a link
um eventually there is it's not to keep
you out it's really just because there's
so so many people I have no idea what to
do
okay is this already in the line endings
recommit
ah pre-commit config
mixed mixed line and it's in
it's in
why do we have
huh
okay
um next line ending
foreign
Fix Auto
Fix Auto
fix no
how do how do I change all
um
change all line endings to LF
for a whole directory tree that's what I
want
those to Unix
fairly straightforward
what is this
Linux command dos to Unix
it's a utility can I have that unlock
nope
let's see
you should use chat GBC to approve yes
am I right by saying we're training an
open source initiative chat bot for when
chat GPT
becomes paid again it's an alternative I
would say and it's gonna be better
yeah
um
is this a real project or a functional
demo this is a real project uh this this
is
an actual thing okay we we have
something now so let's go here let's go
here
and I am I am really bad at find
commands so whoop
foreign
we probably don't need node modules to
be converted right right
uh
lucid dreams posted about this open
sources from the GitHub very cool
um I haven't seen him around yet
um I know he has his an implementation
uh but I haven't I haven't seen him
around yet
so Lobby
more people hello people
hello
hi
very cool hello
thank you
very cool
ah need the mouse
okay people I'll do these cool people
will have to wait like a tiny bit
um
cool
and we're going to go into actual things
to do
excellent hello
cool
all right all right
um
let's see
okay so we have a Discord bot
for dust Unix try using to do it in
parallel that would have been that would
have been a good idea we can just we can
do we really need to do we denote
modules
well they're probably not they're
probably not
ah
I probably don't need the node modules
and they have to exclude it somehow
well what was the issue exactly
no here
no
here
n npm
npm
foreign
T fix
I can fix things in m npm
um
foreign
okay
so here's a bug we don't know where the
bug is this is in this
we call it to do
make it a priority this is actually very
urgent like this is this is blocking
people
on Windows
let's call it high
we're very careful with urgent
hmm
this is still going in the node modules
it's actually good maybe that I'm not
doing it in parallel because the machine
is already Breathing heavily
okay
so we have this oh let me read the other
other messages first that are going on
back end
okay
yep okay
so
very good
just more people coming in
hello
hi pyro I've seen you around our Discord
that's very cool
cool nice
hmm
yes we'll get open Assistant to every PC
in 2024
if there are still PCS
all right so let's get into the GitHub
issues this is the this is the meat
yes I am a manager now
look at this this all issues all from
open assistant
okay
let's follow up
yes I can do that that's awesome
that means I don't have to do something
no thank you thank you for doing it uh
try supervised fighting sure I can do
that is look I mean
that is perfect
again
fixed
don't need to look at this download
transcript of Khan Academy
okay
hmm
so we always look whether stuff is
categorized correctly this seems to be
categorized correctly
uh with the creative comments share a
like license for videos be a problem
might entangle the transcripts yep
that's something we have to
pay attention to
I'm not sure
how we should we should manage that we
should just keep it
in mind
okay so if soon as someone actually does
something here
once we check in the code for this we
will have to also make sure that we're
aware of the licenses here but so far no
one has done or
um this person is working on it but no
one has done something so I think that's
fine all right
these are my days now my days is I work
for the startup during the day and then
I go home and then I I do that
um
collapse texts that are too long in
tasks yeah yeah
with a small screen it may happen that
the text proposed solution have a max
amount of characters collapse the text
even more is present
um
well sure
[Music]
um
all right so yeah this is a front-end
issue it's not part of the project yet
we have a project board if you want to
go look it's to do
yeah it's certainly it's like a medium
priority
I would say it's a small task
um and yes it's indeed a good first
issue for someone who wants to get into
into the project
sounds like a normie job I am an army
I'm I'm sorry
you can transcribe videos using whisper
but we are already complicating the
project yes there's a lot of data
Gathering going on that is not
necessarily part of the first like of
the MVP
um the MVP is really just gonna be to
collect human prompts yeah
add a rest API endpoints to manage users
to view and edit users user IDs
okay
let's buy Andreas that's
very thorough
same some endpoints Implement data okay
good so
this is back end it's probably not a
good first issue because
uh yeah it needs needs a bit of internal
knowledge
foreign
did you check the new embedding from
open AI I I did I got their their email
that they're now better and cheaper so
that's good they must feel a bit of
competitive pressure
what does the rest
in rest API mean
um
you know I knew that at some point
hmm
what does rest in rest API stand for
representational State transfer
good James was faster
yeah I I once had a a job interview
um when I was still studying and I they
had this interview day
and I thought you know I knew a lot and
then they caught me off guard they were
like
what does assets stand for in in asset
transactions what does assets do I'm
like oh
what are we doing we are
being a manager
over here we're going to notifications
we look at notification
then we decide what to do
Harvest Stock Exchange q and a data
stack exchange after reading discussion
how to build
um
um
keep in mind that the
main goal is
task diver City
we'd need to focus on that
when scraping any
Source but
stack Exchange
in itself
okay
that's fairly good there's no
assignment yet that could be a good
first issue
I don't need to know too much about the
project to investigate
scraping data
um that's a large task I would say
they're describing always takes longer
than one one things what are those
noises it could be the fan
it could be the fan of the MacBook I'll
try to sit further away
let's see do I have noise cancellation
on here
um
I do have noise suppression
or are there other noises
I'm running experiments for supervised
fine-tuning for 175 B model with
adapters from school how should I
organize the work should I join Supras
fine tuning issue or another one uh
I guess you can make your own if you do
something very specific
um
yeah and and just
I'm not sure if you can assign labels
otherwise I'll assign it the the ml
label
uh currently I I did a user
um called sotiris is is gathering a bit
what's happening on the ml side because
it's wild the ml side of this is wild
yeah
I just joined is there a tldr if you go
to the repository linked above there is
all the information you need they meant
the chewing noise I'm chewing chocolate
yes
I I'm I need I need calories I haven't
eaten yet today
create a UI for messages API endpoints
user Global message tree views
that is crazy
all these doing this I guess
I hope
priority
that's probably uh it's probably a bit
larger no
well it depends who does it it would be
large for me
thank you
tldr we are making Jarvis actually we
are making Jarvis yes
will there be a recording of This live
stream hopefully if I don't say
something insanely stupid
foreign
write a quick test Suite well we should
probably not call this live stream
coding because I'm not gonna I'm not
doing a bunch of coding I'll I'll do
some I if if I'm through the issues we
can do some coding write the quick tests
yep
quickly test the branch yes that's very
good
we need some manual tests as well
foreign
to do testing is for some reason testing
is the thing that people don't
immediately grab almost any issue no
actually I'm I'm wrong there are some
definitely some some people who take
testing issues
basic red red is set up
very cool so
some some merge conflicts
merging is blocked
okay okay wait
I need to do something here
do you think it's necessary to find for
removed at the back end label added
redis linting prettier removed local
volume cool all right so I'll re-review
this
look at that
why does open AI specifically mentioned
that they are not accessing the web for
information Trio and that's obviously
the next step
open AI it seems I don't know but it
seems like they're very concerned about
PR negative PR which maybe maybe you
know they are correct in being super
worried super paranoid about this but
they want to make sure that this thing
not does nothing doesn't ever do
anything that's out of the ordinary or
could land them in hot Waters or
anything like this now imagine this
thing could actually surf the web
you could probably steer it into a
direction by making some kind of website
putting something in there having
instructing the thing so that it finds
your website or something like this it's
just it's just a lot more dangerous than
a hermetic system
um
yeah but I agree things will go there
do you have any opinion the S4
architecture I I think I think it's a
viable architecture if you need longer
range dependencies but I think the
dependencies themselves are not as let's
say powerful like they're not as Dynamic
so I would guess it's a bit weaker than
a the like attention
um
in terms of the complexity of things
that it can do but it's better at
incorporating longer range dependencies
though
uh-huh
worried about the public perception yes
check the Discord I will later
it's I I could be there all day like I
need to batch it
um but you yeah it's really for work
coordination you can be part of part of
the project at any like the GitHub is a
great place and so on okay so we have
redis
good
well now this doesn't
seem to work redis data but there is no
volume anymore
no
set up redis yeah
foreign
here
there's no volume
yeah the ansible
probably doesn't work
but this one maybe let's check that out
together
so this pulls up or at this image always
restarting which I guess is good Port
exposing that's fine for now we have a
firewall
um
checking that's good
command server with a config file
we Mount the config file at that place
and we have an insights host
that seems reasonable
reasonable
this is the config file now for the
ansible we need a bit of
we probably don't want this but
we're gonna want
the same
we're going to want the config file
um
okay
could you remove
the ansible
part
so we can get this merged
I'll take care of it late
um
can you also make a new
or
I'll take that myself
and do it later
because that's it's I don't think it's
gonna work
uh with the ansible part
um yeah
unable to run recommit all right we
already dealt with that that sucks
I think the project needs a better
documentation I can do that create an
issue in that and ask
on that and ask people what I write
there
I think you can just go ahead and make a
pull request and we can discuss in the
pull request what might be good better
and so on
um
uh I think we are we welcome most I mean
we have to see that it's a bit
streamlined right it's not like any
additional documentation is fine because
that also increases the noise and the
amount of things people need to read but
in general I think
um more helpful documentation is is
better so I I think that will go pretty
well
um
foreign
accessing the web could be implemented
in the training process of course of
course it can but we will have to do
that in a second step the first step is
really to get this chat assistant uh
going
um
Google show that they could use
information retrieved from the web yes
absolutely you can you can do that
see more negative reactions from people
than I've expected about AI in General
open S paranoia like a valid concern I
guess especially like like The
Regulators are are itching like the
regulator fingers are like
the European Union is on this as we
speak you can always count on them to
poop at every I'd like to completely
poop the party of every new thing that
comes across
um
Sam Altman made a comment
gradually to not alarm
Maybe
also really like really convenient that
that's what you know means they don't
release the model and
make more money
okay
um which bought permission
document required in the Bots readme
that's a very good issue very good issue
for people who Wanna
probably medium because we already have
our bot but
um yeah
um
right I want it this never shrinks does
it this list never shrinks
um
okay
we can stay with
G zip Json
line files
we can
into other formats easily
foreign
okay so I'll assign
this person thank you very much
for taking this on
what are you thinking about as the base
model
um
depends so we are investigating multiple
things like T5 on the smaller side and
like the really big models on the larger
side but it's gonna come down to
so the really big models the idea there
would be to then distill them
so yeah
uh but the small models might also be
helpful I'm I'm keeping one eye on
something like uh code gen or however
that's called like coding models because
open AI said that their new DaVinci
models are based on codex models which I
find really surprising
I want to build some basic assistant got
some best options given that I'm limited
to eight gigabytes
well there's no it's not it's not going
to be easy
there's no straightforward way to build
an assistant right now except like
if you're on the chatbot for some very
specific task you can do that but then
you can just also program it no
hmm
um
no worries
that's cool
um
foreign
to the
Discord bot
read me
good
adding pop over to flag text with labels
that's very cool
Fozzy is on it
ABD is on it
very cool people are on it nothing for
me to do thank you very much I will add
it oh no this is a pull request I
usually add issues to the project
board
clean up all eslint warnings
PR
199.
excellenter warnings
cool
um
let's assign there's a branch 199
0
nice
I am a secretary I am a secretary
this is
actually it's cool
I it's absolutely great that so many
people want to contribute I'm more than
happy to be full-time secretary for this
more than happy
I'm working on pulling transcripts you
could to channel can do this for Khan
Academy what channels do you want what
format
oh I I think people discussed this in
the issue
maybe something like karpati did for the
Lex podcasts
um
but
I think Rod like text files would also
be fine since we're not really
interested in coordinating it with the
source material like with the pictures
the same data set might be useful for a
future project to train like some sort
of a video clip or something like this
but for us right now we I kind of we
just kind of want the text
um so up to you I think
you mentioned the plan with large is to
distill them is imperative that we steal
them or do we consider offloading
distributed we can consider we can
consider many things distilling so um
distilling means that you take a large
model and you try to like transfer the
transfer the capabilities to a smaller
model so use the larger as the teacher
model and the smaller one as the
um student model and that usually works
okay ish now
if you
yeah we can think of other things with
the larger model but I really would like
this to result in something that people
can run in some way right in some
reasonable way so that it's not hosted
you know on some super cluster because
once you host it sorry once you host it
on some super cluster it also costs
considerable money to do inference on it
right and that means we can't just bleed
money like it's very cool that people
want to help here and I'm pretty sure
with some donations we could also go
somewhere but we can't just bleed money
for inference and that means
um
that you know we'd have to start making
it a paid service just to to cover the
cost cover the maintenance and so on and
we'll probably have to hire people to
keep it maintained since it's now a paid
service so people actually expect
quality or reliability which makes the
price even higher because you now have
to pay these people it just seems
easier to make a model that you can push
out to people as the model and then they
can find ways of running it
yeah that's my opinion but
um
there's a new yet contrastive search
I've seen that that's very cool
you think all you our Normie computers
are up to it yet no no the first
iteration of this will not run on an
army computer but it will be in the
ballpark hopefully in the Box such that
people with better than Normie computers
can take it can play with it and can
compress it and can make it run on more
Normie computers and so on like the same
that happened with stable diffusion
foreign
on an army computer
I played with the end-to-end demo saw a
bog on the page submit a rating twice
very good bug report
thank you for catching this
very nice
okay okay
all right I've requested a review again
from Andreas
I hope that's gonna happen
at some point our user to link their
Discord account after registering with
email
quite a hassle
yeah I get it
allow dangerous email account linking is
true
um
doesn't react have some property that
says dangerously set inner HTML or
something like this yeah
um what kind of vram would it be able to
run on I'm not sure yet we we don't know
yet we're collecting the human data so
I'm looking at the high level protocol
architecture am I right to say the
protocol would ultimately help in
fine-tuning training as well as the
actual assistant tasks the sure the
protocol can help in the assistant tasks
as well but it's really it's really for
data collection for now
um
yeah
also it's too complicated I I had I had
a brain fart when I made this
um I thought all the front ends should
be
okay
very cool thank you for thank you for
figuring this out
okay there's nothing to do here I guess
until someone picks it up
is it possible these algorithms like
deep sparse on language models like chat
GPT would help lower the computational
yes it would I guess just take longer
you can trade off with some sort of
offloading detox yes nice look at that
pre-commit ran
now we're good to go
a big part of my job is to yell at
people to run pre-commit
it's a good tool but you have to install
it once like you have to install it in
your repo
um I added my essay for data
documentation of data oh sorry
argumentation should have the
augmentation
argumentation oh okay
turns an essay into ah argumentation it
turns an essay into a set of
instructions I also did some much needed
work on docs added a file about data
argumentations anyone can check what
that means and how they can contribute I
also move prompting guide to docs as I
think it should be there makes it easier
to find
add another notebooks for essay revision
very cool
very cool
very cool okay
this does it have a label
um I'll assign the label documentation
even though it also has
like notebooks
actually documentation and ml
thank you
okay
all right so where are we at
data argumentation
is a Technique we can use to get better
data faster doesn't every that should
that's I want that I want better data
faster
I can use this to get better data faster
that's amazing
using machine learning models to analyze
long data compress it into instructions
that's actually smart
contribute we can write a short python
script to use this model from hogging
face to analyze the text
or examples what you can do
and
example implementations very cool to
contribute
instructions that's a notebook
let's say revision that's a notebook
essay instructions is a notebook that
takes an essay and generates
instructions on how to generate that
essay
will be very useful for data collecting
for the model I agree
okay
that all seems
reasonable
that seems reasonable cool
um perfect perfect
all right
yes I have no comments
perfect
awesome
thank you very much
it's very productive
okay
pre-commits still failing let's see
better data faster no song by Daft Punk
yep
all right prettier is not happy
and the file fixer
is not happy
good
could you run pre-commit run all files
to make the linter happy
all right now before yes we run
something here
let's see whether that ran that's good
to merge merging
nice
perfect perfect
amazing
that's a merge pull request I love those
use chat GPT to make chat jbt that
that is the
Singularity no
fixing linter warnings okay I don't
have to do something here
I think
checks have passed but code on review is
required once checks have passed we can
probably activate eslint itself not just
next lint
um supervised data
that's a big issue
uh-huh
transcriptions
mm-hmm
better than nothing model we can use
knowledge demonstration as context for
human allotakers yes that's correct I'll
read this
I read this issue later because I don't
really know what to do with it right now
because it's a bit
not really
an issue write a bot to backend
communication test
the issue could benefit from a contract
test
you should test that each call satisfied
the open API schema inputs an input that
way changes the input contract
automatically cost by this test to
retrieve yes
hard code the response model and
endpoints for these tests creates more
maintenance burden
ef2
yeah
put up the back and you'll need the
database and redis
foreign
what would be the overhead
tests
if I change
the
API in the back end and change
the Bots API client
very accordingly
such that everything works do I also
have to change something in the account
test
if not
that would be really cool
and definitely
good way to go
if yes it's a bit more tricky as it
might mean big overhead
um also
for
I think
we could use
existing Docker compose setup
there is a pi test plugin
for this
and I think we already have code two
uh create some sample data
okay
it would be really cool like I don't
want to discourage this this seems this
seems like a very good
very good way to go to do one of these
con I've just never heard of contract
tests so but if they really work with
the schema then why not
um
Harvest stock exchange data for scraping
online dumps that might prove useful
here's an example thank you
download transcripts of Khan Academy yes
working on this for another project
here's some code
modified code from
you'll also need to get all YouTube
video IDs
okay
Google is constantly upgrading
transcription I suspect all the pins it
might be out of date quickly yes
that is very good input thank you
collapse texts that are too long that
won't solve the problem if you have a
fixed text with text wrap in two lines
there will be
okay I thought of something like
overflow or
hidden with L with text
overflow ellipses or some
like that
tricky
character limit seems fine
what step are we on right now step
I don't know what's step three what's
that step step one is steel underwear
step three is profit
I I get I guess some of you might be too
young for this one
to remember this anyone having issue
with the docker compose what's the issue
with the docker compose
yo what's step two
um anyone having issue with the docker
yeah the docker compose
supervised Phantom check parameter
efficient fine tuning for large models
based on Discord conversation
might be the training adapters from much
larger models would be to result in a
better model than training a small model
fully that's correct how to check we
already have an issue for supervised
training so we can borrow a setup to
test with two public models available
yeah
take a big model
finding all parameters take a large
model and train with the following
methods and then check how does it
affect the quality if the large model is
better but e might be better to still
Alternatives yes
it's working extreme quantization very
cool
yeah Bloom is as far as I can tell oh
you very much for the
agree the plan is
foreign
we absolutely need to know know how much
the
between small and large all those is
um
my limited view
opt seems
or
suitable of the two both because of the
license
I also believe
performance wise it is
a bit better
correct me if I'm wrong
nice
yes
I agree with the rocket
okay
um
labels
ml
excellent
projects this one
this is
I want to say well the priority given
how much stuff I've assigned medium
priority I want to assign this low
priority which doesn't mean it's not to
do it's just we don't necessarily need
it for the first milestone
um
but I'll up Priority once it it comes
closer to being important
isn't Bloom 175d parameter model yes
it's very big
like your mama
a Docker ah okay okay Docker compose
the compose file is invalid
what service backup is neither an image
nor a build for wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait oh
well the doors to Unix ran and there are
no changed files
so okay so that issue must be something
else there wait okay
um
Docker compose up build
foreign
all good
all good no
um
do we uh no Docker compose
yes
it says unknown flag but yes you need I
think someone here there's something
with
Docker compose run it without the dash
so Docker compose with the dash oh no
you ran it without the dash
unknown
parameter build
unknown flag build
the same person
to complained here
oh no no anyone having issue with
there's something in Doc wrong and
Docker compose well it's
to to to
um
to get into danger of of uttering the
meme but it works on my machine
foreign
[Music]
but it does
the creator of Ark thinks he's not a
good programmer
well what is a good programmer if you
get stuff done
and that's you're like good for many
things and then there is the aspect of
getting stuff done in ways that is
future proof
which makes it a bit better
and then
um
there is also
to write things in a way that are future
proof and compatible with how other
people write things that's kind of The
Next Step
I would say
because writing code in a team is is
different you have to make a few
compromises
um
yes yes
okay perfect
yes that is
amazing
has to be different Docker and Docker
composed versions yeah Docker compose as
far as I know is now included in Docker
so if you write it without the dash like
Docker composers two words
so yeah I'm I'm not sure what the
problem is but here at least it builds
yeah what's my Docker version
compose is not a dog yeah it might be a
bit old
or I'm not sure so I'm on 2010-21
on a Mac Mac OS
thank you
update the prompting guide provide
accurate reliable information using
credible source and reference as
appropriate avoid providing vague or
incomplete response very cool yes yes
yes yes yes
that seems very reasonable
thank you
okay
need to approve running pre-commit and
I'm going to guess pre-commit will yell
because it always does
why need a team when you have large
language models
we can hopefully check compare the
performance by testing both
the suggestion on
they also have
yes
agree
this is what a typical Tech manager
looks like
okay unable to run
just did a fresh copy
hmm
that sucks
foreign
from where
hmm I think this is the problem WSL is
using the windows npm
you can install
yes
this might actually be this is a good
this is a very nice analysis because
pretty sure this means that in this file
the line endings are maybe wrong
you think human what beings are
stochastic part yeah I think the most
like the most
um important thing that comes out of
this whole language model research isn't
necessarily how good the language models
are but that probably humans aren't
doing much more
then
interpolating things they've seen before
so
yeah I'm I'm fairly I'm fairly sure
okay this is good
merge it nice
excellent this is a pleasure
okay we have merge commit
yeah okay now we can actually think of
doing something
so
um Andreas has sent around
so here in bot we can look at that
we can work so let's go
work complete the task no I don't want
to type I just want to work
check your DMs what look at this
this is cool
rank initial prompt rank the following
tasks from best to worst
okay what do I do now
I accept the task
huh
please type your response here okay wait
prompt one prompt these I mean these I'm
I'm having trouble could you clean my
room please that's the best prompt so
five is the best
definitely two is the next best
one I'll just go by length one three and
four then okay does that work task
complete would you like another task yes
of course I would like another task
rank the following rank user reply and
here it says rank the following task
that's already a bug
that's a book
tasks rank the following tasks
from best to worst
I can file a bug I could just fix it but
I can also file a bug
um not the pull request an issue I want
an issue yes
new issue
is rlhf system which automated from
Discord
the will that will not recollect the
data with Discord and then we do the
reinforcement learning uh on somewhere
um
but each human mind has a character
sheet with different training history
that's true yes but it it's it's still
the case that humans probably just do
that right they just interpolate what's
your take on binary feedback versus
preference ranking
about binary feedback is also preference
ranking but if you if you think of wait
let me make this issue real quick
um but task says
e user
replies
but description says
rank tasks
okay this is a bug it's part of the bot
it's probably a good first issue because
I mean I'm not I suppose that it's not
gonna be that hard
um to do
that is medium it's not a blocker and
it's kind of it's tiny
but still it's an issue good task time
that what
give give me come on give me task give
me task okay
I should be able to write work here no
next task Maybe
no it's just hanging
um okay we can make an issue for that
um I should be able to ask the
bot for work in
the DMs
so far I can ask for work in the
actually no because our main problem
with the Discord bot is that we almost
need you to go to the DMS to do the work
because otherwise it's too much noise
but we still want to keep the sort of
community aspect alive so if people if
people go in here and request work at
least other people
see
hmm
no they can't because it's deleting my
messages okay
well then it makes sense okay do we have
okay now I should be able to ask
the bot for work in DMs
so far I have to go
to the channel to ask for work
but then it transfers me to the DMs
if the task times out but I like
another one
I have to go back
to the channel
it would be more convenient
if I could just also type
work in the DMs
right that does not that doesn't work no
yeah I didn't do it okay
all right we'll assign it but
foreign
and we'll do that we'll do that oh no to
do
it's probably not it's medium priority
small task nice good
why open vs code when I can get someone
else to it well
I have that I I watched the talk on
managing open source and it really it
set essentially that like even for the
small stuff try to make issues to get
other people just
um because it's also a like a small
issue is also a chance for someone who
wants to participate but doesn't feel
like oh I don't want to take on a big
task right because then I'm like a
blocker if I don't figure it out or
maybe they feel they're not capable
enough like small tasks are really good
for getting people on board who want to
help who want to do something
um and you know just get them
on board and and through the motion
maybe they'll see a bit of the code and
once they went through it once they'll
feel more comfortable with the code base
or at least the part that they saw
um they have to they'll have to do a Dev
setup to test it out maybe so I think
it's yeah I think it's right to to to to
to do that even the small tasks sort of
give them away
okay
on it
all right let's let's go back let's make
some work
check your DMs of course user reply
send the next message in the
conversation as if you were the user hi
assistant hey buddy how can I serve you
okay so this is a conversation
um
when do you think we can start data
labeling hopefully next week
like it's a bit ambitious but hopefully
next week
we're like we are full steam
flamethrower open working to get this up
uh
yeah
send the next message
in the conversation as if you were the
user
um hey buddy how can I serve you
um okay okay so
accept please type your response here of
where
can I get pizza at this time of day
task completed would you like another
task yes
okay rank assistant reply rank the
following tasks
from best this it still says tasks I
would get I would guess that's that
should go into the same
the same book now
hopefully hopefully
also happens for
reply
to Doom good
except
I'm unsure oh
rank assistant reply I'm not sure how to
interpret we don't have the conversation
I think that there's already an issue
for we don't have the the conversation
that happened beforehand we're supposed
to rank these
[Music]
um
but we don't know what the conversation
before is so
how okay let's just rank them like this
task completed would you like another
task yes
rank initial prompt we already did that
oh no this is different
wait
hmm
um but
hey um
just trying out the bot I have already
made a few
issues on GitHub
just a question is it possible
no wait that goes to backend
foreign
the
data that is used for the tasks is not
correctly filtered
for example I did a few
ranking tasks and entered
things like five
[Music]
which is fine
but then I got
more ranking tasks and I saw the string
five
um
as one of the replies of the
initial prompts right
timed out well thank you
um oh was I here
one of the initial
I was supposed to rank
but
just because I in
that it's not
initial prompt or any
session message
it's just
what is this a bug
or just the test data is random strings
attach the picture
this is
in backend Channel because it's probably
that back end issue okay
got Docker composed to work nice good
job
at the end of 2023 Sam Altman has armies
of capitalist Walker pots fighting our
general ionic Bots
invoking all
the arrays versus the tensor
what's your opinion on the forward
forward algorithm by Jeff hint I'm
halfway through the paper I'm getting
through papers really slowly because I'm
working on this so much but so far he
he's hedging a lot right he's um he's
saying well this is uh we've tried it on
mnist it's just good for this and this
and this we'll see
um usually hidden has ideas and and
small tests and so on but a lot of
things work like as an idea and in small
tests and then underwhelm when you scale
them up so it remains to be seen which
whether it's really like something new
and uh viable or not
um
where do the weights come from we will
we will train them we are going to train
them
um yeah
okay work
idioms
rank the following from best to worst
okay I mean this this generally seems to
work no
task completed
okay what if I enter
send the next message how can I help you
go away
okay
yes
okay what if I just
do this invalid response nice
so let's try one that is not in there
two four five
invalid respond nice good good good good
good
two three invalid response one two three
four five
tasks completed nice good
wait we are going to get the weights at
the gym obviously we're gonna get
weights at the gym
uh
where's the training money come from you
might like this might seem strange but
money is not that much of an issue
for this project there are enough people
interested
and enough organizations who might want
to sponsor try extra comma at the end
comma oh yes good job good excellent
excellent idea
more
aha accept hopefully it's a ranking task
the initial prompt ask the assistant
initial prompt
um
oh
right and
email to
my landlord
[Music]
asking them to reduce rent
good
rank nice so this this like this
oh no wait I need to accept okay
invalid response see
it should say why it's invalid in nice
clear language
that might be a bit harder because we uh
probably validated it against some some
regex and it's it's hard to say but yes
I agree that might be
might be ux
what about negative one and zero
negative one would do
negative one
zero negative one one
zero two
it works it works select star from and
zero
see
duplicate numbers we we tried that
nope
will it be named Chad GPT nice
uh what about one plus zero two
invalid response one comma comma two
invalid response look
0.5
and no 1.5 and 2.
it works it actually works you can't you
can't fool it null
two
no no
can't fool it zero on zero two
God responds drop table let's go let's
go drop table
drop table
invalid response
see
doesn't work
zero zero one two
this is Agi you can't fool it
try longer response one
comma
two
response
uh 10 e minus one
two
no
uh we could just go
look up what the code is but so far I
think yeah
one two three four five seven eight nine
no no we tried longer ones we we did it
through nine we can't you can't just put
in a reg X into regex validation no no
no we're good we're good we tried every
every possible thing do you know this
joke there's this joke that
a QA engineer comes into a bar
and asks for one beer asked for 99 beers
ask for 9999 beers asks for Nan beers
asks for negative one beers
and
everything's fine and then a real
customer comes into the bar and asks
where the bathroom is and the bar
explodes
that's the joke one of our Engineers
told me that it's very funny
foreign
well I'm I'm in Discord Discord probably
already sanitizes the response
we should stick these into mutedness
yeah
new line at the end one two
yeah that works okay so new lines are
fine I guess we do strip
like we strip
hey buddy how can I serve you bring me a
sandwich
I don't know how to write sandwich like
this
um rank okay so what if we do one two
three four five
invalid response
one two three four five
that works see is that Discord Discord
strips new lines at the beginning at the
end
another task
initial prompt
what's up
dog what's up dog
aha
well I want more cookies
rank three replies
bring me a see this is my this is my
input yes so
um three two one like this right
oh no need to accept
three two one
invalid response see
let's overwhelm it
you're sitting enter the chills
okay okay
all right
okay good we made it
foreign
in open Assistant land I'll take care of
this see there's
there's already stuff again
I should be able to ask
shouldn't be that hard I can try to do
this amazing thank you
I hear the bot code is kind of cursed
because people tried out different
Frameworks
which group or company started this
project that I
um there's no company
um it runs under lion the people who
made lion 5B the data set
and it's a bunch of people who started
it including myself I would say I would
say I was among the people
started it but
um yeah it's it's fully open so write
instructions for unit testing python
code
foreign
[Music]
thank you
why is accept button needed I think the
task times out if you don't accept it in
time but if you accept it you might have
a bit more time I'm not sure why the
except but
I'll I'll leave that to the to the bot
people write about to backend
communication test
aha okay
um
since first API automatically generates
the contract and you change the API were
nice cool cool
and my experience creates hidden
coupling yes you're right
very cool
thanks for the inputs
could you make another issue for
tests
like then assign it to you
will leave this issue for
um
that more and to end
the book test
thank you
okay
um
well
Yannick is head of PRS
is a way we can stop Yale safety
researchers from getting in I thought
Stanford was the the big boo
wise accept button yeah
um
how about telegram it's pretty easy to
get a bot running over there we could
have a telegram we could have a telegram
bot
I mean that's certainly viable
I think yeah if someone wants to take on
that
so the idea here is that the back end is
agnostic to towards the front end uh you
can write any kind of front and we could
also another idea is to have a gradual
front end
can write any front end you want
um
Yeah the more the merrier
happy New Year thank you you too all of
you too
Discord Bots are mad easy to make too
you would think so
but people have been discussing a lot
exiting goodbye
well goodbye and that's kind of passive
positive aggressive
um
let's see
what's up front end yeah Google Google
Plus Google Plus front end that's it
Friendster front end
um
could you make an issue
for that
let's
see if anyone wants to take that on
for anyone setting this up on Debian
based distros you need to apt install
Docker compose plugin
unfortunate
let's begin Club Penguin front end
that's it
um Ian if you if you want to you could
make a pull request
um maybe in the readme
uh maybe we can have a section like FAQ
or something like this and then just
your error message and then the the
solution just very briefly like if you
get this error do this that'd be really
cool
um
if you want obviously
um yeah
4chan will get Stanford involved that
would be that would be ironic
if they if they figure the best way of
trolling us would be
to get Stanford involved
they can yeah
your chat front and semi-unironically
yeah
thank you Ian
um
we can have all kinds of stuff
yep
thank you for being here I will look at
these later
um yes so the question is do we do
something now do we code something
because I titled this thing coding live
stream so
um at least I should
be doing something now the question is a
little bit
what
so
what I wanted to do is a little bit of
this end to end testing which no one has
yet quite done we have Cyprus tests
going which I feel might be doing this
because they test the website as such
um
what could we do right let's actually
look over the issues why do we have the
issues if
so so where's the project board
here
as in data
uh this is also a pre-commit run
some checks haven't completed yet must
be resolved
yes it does some fixes and it
or other things it just yells at you you
can
pre-commit install so it does it
in the
and prevents committing
if things aren't okay
now
there appear to be
clicks preventing Auto merge
could you
merge Origins
main into yours and
and then
push again
thank you
track tests thank you
very much
label Bots
amazing and testing
and
project
we are in progress we are in priority
that's probably fairly decent fairly
decent chunk of work no
good
well if I do Docker compose it says my
Docker compose file is invalid but
that's the problem Ian had right are you
sure your Docker is up to date
and did you install the docker compose
plugin
um this answer right here
cool
I'm not sure if I should assign Jack
here too because
the original thing was for the
but I will not do it yet
so
that's probably also a decent chunk of
work
okay we are not far away from again
having cleared
our
if you installed Docker of both pluggage
you get an invalid if you install the
Ubuntu Docker compose package rather
than the plugin you'll get an invalid
Docker ah nice okay so this might be
you need to plug in
not that
this is it's just a big issue it's just
called supervised data we need to split
it up somehow but let's look at
let's look at something can we do
something small or big
can we do something that makes people's
lives useful
let's go to the issues
the project board
to do and not assigned
okay let's go to small issues unable to
run pre-commit that's ongoing collapse
texts I'm not
web Webby for that
bot tests I will leave this for someone
else
no that's probably hard
re-evaluate the design description of
tasks write the website the backend
these are tests structure the website
code for better collaboration
that's probably how that's probably a
decent that's like I would say this is
large
Implement text labels can fetch tasks
when logging in as the debug user
okay
it seems that when using debug no user
entry I think we can use one of next off
hooks to make this use correctly but
I'll need to check this we can do this
we can do this
are you on a newer-ish version of
I'm not sure oh here
Docker version 2010 12. that's mine too
no
2010-21 I'm on but it's probably more
the
maybe the Ubuntu I'm not sure
yes it is messy
would be happy for any kind of inputs
all right let's do that so how do we
develop this thing
um what you can do is so right now I'm
gonna I wanna do something in the front
end right
so I'm navigating to this folder right
um to the front end development there is
a readme
and that says what you can run in order
to pull up all the dependencies of the
front end
so if you run this and if Docker compose
works for you then that should pull up
a database the back end and so on all
kinds of stuff that you need in order to
um
run
a front end
so that's one thing oh wait oh this is
already running
ah
this was running from before
cancel it
cancel it Docker compose down
good
nice stop stop it down
good trash it
all right so this will set up the back
end and whatnot and now we can run the
front end so in order to run the front
end
we can go to the oh to the website
directory
and we can just npm run
uh
death
I think so yeah
so
we go here and we should technically see
the open Assistant website
excellent cool
okay what was the bug again we need to
know what the bug was
can't here let me close all of this
can't fetch tasks when logging in as a
debug user the website writes a copy of
a fetch test the local database
associated with the user ID
okay so how about
we
reply as assistant
we'll click on that
no tasks found I see
what if we register with email instead
sign in
with email test at test.com
now you have to go through the to the
mail
um client who
public user does not exist
uh
so there's a readme
the website has a readme on how to get
it running we need to push the database
schema
search for Prisma
here
npx oh
install first
pull new dependencies
have you been using GitHub copilot yes I
have
this project going to be similar to open
AI models in Hardware requirements we'll
be able to run it in a modest home PC
the goal is to make it runnable on
consumer Hardware
now at the beginning we might not get
there fully but the goal is uh to get
there so that people can run it
themselves and you don't have to have
like a super cluster
um yeah
that's
that's the hope but you know good
we'll see we'll see what happens
I I hope so
okay
npm install was a mistake as it always
is
let's see what's going on here
site
foreign
good
oh come on npm
reify this
so once
we have that we can ah there we go
um now we need
we need to push the schema to the
database that's very important
prixma I am an idiot
and now we can start
so you saw the URL here this is the mail
thing that runs so
it's like a little inbox
um now receiving email good so we'll
continue with this again
let's hope that works
no email
ah we're just up and running now good
there we go
yes sign in
and we are logged in
so what happens if I hear reply as
assistant
is it different there are tasks okay
okay
this is it we got a bug we're gonna
solve the bug
I hope
no no big words
um okay
so in the
source
um we'll need to find out where the
whole
pages auth
sign in
no I guess
there's like a next auth page where the
providers are defined
so there's an email provider
and apparently that pushes stuff to the
database
um and our
our debug provider does not
so now we need to see why does one do
that and the other one doesn't
right
yep so the Discord provider as well it
just it's just there
like
okay
next of credentials save
to database actually let's let's do the
um I need to log in quickly and I I
think I one second
okay
good all right look at this look at this
this is fun
I'm using a
credentials provider in next off
how can I save
oh
I use it with JWT how can I save
the logged in users into a database I'm
using Prisma
foreign
yes
yes
I know how to create in Prisma I want to
know where in the next auth I need to to
do that
this just explains to me what a database
does
how do I do this in next off
credentials provider
foreign
yes
yes
would you like to learn about databases
I I think I'm not formulating myself
correctly
I hope that helps let me know if I have
many questions okay
using the next auth credentials provider
with the database Google is still number
one
Google
yes
what
what okay limitation being annoying I
don't like where this is going
I don't like that at all
I don't like it at all
sign in yes no this is way too much code
yes
next it comes built in support
the user provided authorized callback
function yes
ensure you define a callback function I
am defining a callback function
so
um what I'm so here is a Prisma adapter
right
in that just wraps Prisma
that it just seems to wrap
Prisma
from here
right
okay
now why does it not store it into the
into the database
why
I think next off makes that hard on
purpose yes that's what
that's what I figured from this blog
post
enabled user authenticate with the
credential thread are not persisted in
the database
okay let's do it by hand
you're using the yes we're using
sessions but the credentials project can
only be used if Json web tokens are
enabled
so oh
we'll do it manually can't we just hear
in authorize check
whether or not the user exists in the
database
why can't we do that
I'm pretty sure we should be able to do
that here is a schema right so
here's an account session here's the
user
okay
so here's the user
and
um let's say
Prisma user
there
Prisma dot user
we should be able to to get that somehow
no result
what's this username typescript
something
hmm
we should be able to do that
I'm I'm just gonna do something here
let's go back here so this is what we
want to see
now
let's go here sign in test
what we're seeing is not that
not that okay so in authorize let's just
confirm that we are at some place no I
don't want that
we'll just confirm it
or we open a console here as well
no
no
we need to log out login
sorry for the slowness
you can use the JWT callback maybe hmm
there's a hook on sign up to save to
database
hmm
yes those are all reasonable things
but this is for debugging only I want
like the dirtiest thing possible okay
now we reach this point when we log off
and log in again so how why like
save the user to the database
yep yep
yep
see
I didn't even need to do
this is a bit okay we can we can
refactor this like a tiny bit okay so
um we can we
we can we can do we can do a bit better
okay so let's say
user is that
ah
I we no stop it
I took one line too much so
user is this
um
user ID
create the user
and return the user
was that copilot yes that is
I am like all of this I'm not really
good at typescript and things like this
so
remove this useless assignment to
variable it's not used well glad you
changed your mind
foreign
so okay let's do it let's sign out
let's sign in
test it
and
we did log in
let's see if we see the task
I am a coding God I am Lunas Torvalds
foreign
I simply pressed tab when co-pilot told
me what to do that's what I did
all right well that is excellent that is
absolutely excellent we we did we made
the beautiful change look at this this
is amazing
so
all right let's go here oh no here uh
here can't fetch tasks when logging in
as the debug user assign myself
I guess it's not necessary to put it in
progress but
create the branch so if you want to do
work this is what you
I guess you you can Fork the repository
or something like this but
I usually do that let it create a branch
on origin and then I I um
fetch
and you wanna you wanna pull
all main if you can
first it's not and then you want to
check out
that Branch technically I should have
done that before I
Technica I should have done that before
I could also create the branch locally
um yeah but it does the good naming with
the issue number in front of it which I
like Okay
um
saving user to the database
when using the debug
credentials provider
foreign
now this committing takes a bit because
pre-commit runs but it's it's worth it
because
um
yeah I think it's worth it
just because
well that's a lot of output actually
this is a bit long now but that's
because my computer is
breathing
um yeah I should probably
turn that off while it's committing
it usually takes five seconds or so all
right push it up make a pull request
let's go
um
note
that bit hacky
but next off
um
makes it quite trouble some
to do this in a clean way when JWT is
active and
we need JWT because
the credentials provider only supports
that
cool
all right so now
we first of all check up Main
oh where did my pull requests go
here
we label it website
yeah so tests are running and also uh
reviewers are assigned automatically
because of code ownership
I should probably say
that it solves some issue right
solves issue
can't fetch tasks when logging in as
debug user
sounds like half my projects now
uh copilot is really amazing like if
especially if you
if you do anything like business logic
um it's just it's absolutely great what
yeah
okay
cool
all right so we actually did some coding
got it running both on a local VM and on
gcloud nice good good job excellent
thank you
um cool yes so if you want to contribute
here we're there's just a bunch of stuff
to do until we can get the data
collection part out and then there's a
lot of stuff to do namely
doing the data like you saw the tasks
right now the tasks are essentially
either write something write a response
to something or rank different things
um so that's going to be the bulk of the
work I'll be participating myself and
other people too so yeah
um that was it for the stream thank you
so much for being here this was really
cool having you here
um thanks for everyone watching I know
this was a bit more I guess boring with
all the the management stuff but yeah
thanks for being here I wish you an
absolutely happy New Year wherever in
the world you are and I'll see you next
time
bye